welcome back this is always the hardest
time to give class or lecture because
it's right after lunch in the United
States at is nap time so I'm going to
try to keep you alert and oriented
during this and I think one way in which
to keep people alert and oriented is to
threaten you with the fact that on
Friday the delegates are going to do a
presentation using the tools we're about
to go over this afternoon so there's
added incentives to pay attention and
ask questions the other thing I would
ask is if you're using a laptop for
anything except taking notes put it down
because we absolutely need your
attention we need you to participate I
never really just give a straight
lecture I always really try to get the
group involved Siraj knows this he's
been in class with me a lot and I think
this will be a lot more fun for
everybody if it's interactive if there's
something I say that you don't
understand stop me ask me to say it
again
ask me to go slower there's something
you say that I don't understand I'm
going to do the same thing okay good
so what let me get started we're going
to talk about strategic problem-solving
and this is a very important piece of
this conference because we're believing
that being able to solve problems is
ultimately really eight managerial
science and a leadership skill when we
had grand strategy yesterday they talked
a lot big-picture set the strategy know
what your objective is before you go so
I think that's very consistent with what
I'm going to go through but I also I'm
going to try to put a few more steps in
there for what you do after you have set
the big objective so let's start here
thinking strategically what does this
mean the way we're thinking of it we
have the circle on the left side that's
where we are today that's the current
state we're in
and we have the square on the right side
that's where we want to be
that's the desired state that's where we
wish we could be in X amount of years
and the thing that gets you from where
you are today to where you want to be is
your strategy this is thinking
strategically because we're defining
that desired state first so in the terms
of problem-solving and in the terms of
what the delegates have done on your way
and we had a lot of email about this
before we got here you define the
current state and we called it the
problem statement it's the problem it's
the the thing you're dealing with right
now your current state and you also set
an objective of the desired state what
you would like to be doing relative to
that problem where you'd like to be and
our week today is to really think about
how do we design implement and evaluate
that strategy that will get us from the
problem to the objective so that's sort
of the set up of where we're going any
questions about this just before I move
on make sense
ties to before so this is the approach
we are asking you to use and it's an
approach of problem-solving clearly not
the only approach of problem-solving and
I hope with all of your experience a lot
of this will you'll say oh yeah that's
just like something else I learned it's
not meant to be all new to you of course
it should be logical it should be
intuitive but I think structuring the
complex problems you've brought in this
way can help you and us together think
in a kind of rational logical way about
complex problems but also communicate it
we heard so much today of your job as
leaders communicating what's the problem
what am I trying to do and why am I
going to do it and did it work that
maybe this will be some tools that will
help spawn that kind of power in what
your own communication is another theme
as we go through this it's going to be
the use of evidence so I'm hoping that
through this problem-solving
collectively see how often a leader a
great manager a leader is able to embed
evidence to promote problem solving and
that I think is the great synergy of if
we can use research evidence and
evidence to change policy it will be
used if it solves problems because
that's I think what most people really
want to be able to do I'm going to go
through each of these steps with and and
start to get into some examples but you
can read these here define the problem
state the objective conduct a root cause
analysis develop from that possible
strategies you might use compare the
strategies using common criteria make a
choice select the strategy you're going
to go with create an implementation plan
and then create an evaluation plan now
right off the bat I would imagine
anybody who's done evaluation here maybe
Johnny I don't know you're going to say
why is an evaluation plan right at the
top why not write it the first thing do
I want to know what my evaluation plan
is and I would say yes and yes the fact
is there is some linear thought process
but there's a lot of feedback loop to
say okay actually I'm going to change
what I really think my strategy ought to
be now that I know exactly how I'm going
to evaluate it so I do not want to be so
rigid as one two three four five six
seven eight you've got to do it that way
look at it holistically and I think as
we get into the actual material it will
make more sense
okay so defining a problem we won't
spend too much time on this since you
did an awful lot of this before getting
here to this conference over the last
six months or so I'll never forget in a
very beginning when I learned about
quality improvement in the US the
experts at that time said you're going
to figure out the problem in one
tense keep it short the problem is and I
have found this to be tremendously
helpful to focus a group to have a group
be able to communicate the problem to
people above to demonstrate greater
leadership by sort of seeing the forest
for the trees the major problem is and a
primary piece of sort of defining the
problem is being sure it's a problem not
a solution like what would be an example
of saying a problem actually in the
words of a solution can you think of
anything that you might come up with
where you would it's really not a
problem you've given you've given a
solution any ideas right start with we
need like the problem is we need to have
a plan the problem is we needed HR Human
Resources plan that's not really a
problem developing a plan could be a
strategy to some problem you have and
it's not it's not really ultimately an
objective because if all we had were
plans we wouldn't have accomplished
anything that's not the desired state we
don't want to be in a state of we have a
plan we want to be in a state probably
where we actually have human resource
capacity we really have enough qualified
skilled health workers so the idea is to
be sure to state the problem in a way
that it's truly a problem not the
solution or the strategy you would use
address the problem that can be feasibly
solved I think that our groups might
come to terms with this over our we care
that maybe some of these problems are
might be narrowed in some way so they
can be feasibly solved but that's a
critical piece I think to managing
problem solving and choose a problem
that's widely widely agreed upon as a
problem by key constituents and erielle
I think did a nice job of sort of saying
how do you advocate so something will be
a problem for the key constituents
because if Liberia wants to deal with
maternal more
but the key constituents don't doesn't
matter how good a leader you are not
going to happen the key constituents
have to see it as a problem also so
we're starting this after that's already
happened and in fact we tried hard to
get people in the room who had been
asked by their ministry or their senior
leadership team to work on this problem
because it was a priority for you which
was really why we didn't tell you what
problem but have you come with it so
hopefully they're already agreed upon as
a key issue so just examples in defining
a problem so the rest of the people in
the room know what it's going on here
Ethiopia the problem has been defined as
the lack of human resources with
managerial capacity in the health
delivery system with focus on hospitals
reasonable in Ghana the problem has been
defined as they have a lack of a method
to monitor performance of health care
managers in the health system now they
focused on this they lack the method to
monitor I don't know ultimately as you
start to work in your rooms
this problem will statement will be that
health care the performance
characteristics Akoo the lack of ability
to tie financial payment to health
providers performance and quality again
I think that you have decided that you
already have sort of narrowed it to if
we could tie the financial payment to
performance and quality you'd get the
kind of state that you want where you
would have higher quality and higher
performing providers I think that's
where Mexico was headed with this Rwanda
changed your problem statement that's
great flexibility is number one in
leadership so great they
put us all to the test here but Rwanda
changed their problem statement - we
don't have enough skilled health care
workers to meet our healthcare delivery
needs so what's sort of your reaction to
these problems do they all feel like
problems they all feel like they're made
you know you can criticize we work hard
to try to get them to actually be
problems not solutions is that you're
comfortable yeah and you know one you
have you don't have sufficient yeah oh
there are not sufficient skills it's a
good question let's not let's just not
answer it right this second cuz we're
trying to get through the pedagogy but
that's a very important thing and
that'll be part of how you you sit down
when you're really defining this problem
to be as concrete as possible it's the
problem you don't have enough resources
with managerial capacity is that the
quality of the human resources with
managerial capacity what piece of that
will it ultimately be but they I know
have done a lot of thinking about it but
why don't we try to get through what
this approach is and then hopefully
we'll have time to talk about the
specifics so that's the first of the
define the problem the second state the
objective so let's go through this in
terms of stating the objective first we
want to be sure the objective addresses
the problem most times when people start
this they define one problem and then
they set an objective that's fully
different so they might define the
problem as high i maternal mortality
rate ratios and then they set the
objective that we need to reduce costs
in the healthcare system and what we had
hoped you would do is just couple these
things and you have the opportunity to
couple them in other words keep the
problem and the objective totally linked
because you're one team doing this so
often in countries any
we see one team figures out the problem
and another team figures out the
objective and the two just don't come
together at all that's a huge problem
itself you have the luxury of just being
here in this little room and so your
problem and objective can come together
but it's a skill you can use I think in
working in policy and practice to keep
teams back focused on what's the problem
that this objective actually solves so
that they are married together a way to
sort of bring forces together on a
single laser beam effort that you might
want
so in this place we have kept the
objective I'm addressing the problem
keep it short so the other thing you
don't want five pages of objectives
because again you're all about
communicating you can't communicate five
pages of something be sure it's feasible
to attain and be very specific about the
objective who will do what by when and
of course I think all of you have
probably at one time or another studied
the smart objectives of specific
measurable a actionable are realistic T
time-bound good so being able to do that
kind of work which of course can help
set off your evaluation obviously is a
very important thing at this stage you
just go back to the example the each
country set an objective that was not
yet defined with that level of
specificity but it's the beginning which
is Ethiopia enhanced the managerial
capacity of Human Resources in the
delivery system with focus on hospitals
Ghana develop and implement an effective
method to monitor human resource
performance in the Health System Liberia
is working on their objective is to
reduce the maternal mortality ratios by
10 percent by 2010 Mexico develop and
implement systems to tie financial
payment to health providers performance
and quality and last Rwanda developed
skill
healthcare workers to meet healthcare
delivery needs of Rwanda so these are in
each case fully married to their
problems as you work this afternoon to
be sure you like the problem you've got
and it's the right narrow or breadth and
you work on these to make them as
specific as possible with the objectives
they might change slightly but I think
starting now at 135 the problem and the
objective are well married with each
other which is a good thing
any questions about this piece of it
okay so CDC part because you have done
most of this before you got here
let's go to the third step of problem
solving and incidentally number one and
two was easy because we spent a little
bit you know fair amount of time on it
in your countries obviously that's a
huge political and economic discussion
it's really the priority setting which
is gigantic and we had a lot of talks
about just figuring out what priorities
might be this sword this problem-solving
method really assumes okay we can define
a problem starting there now what do we
do to actually make something change and
underlying my desire to go through this
as part of a Leadership Institute is
oftentimes number one and to happen and
then we fall a little flat on three
through eight and you know we we know
this is a priority we know this is what
we're trying to do we write policy
papers or white papers we have w-h-o
meetings we have h8 meetings g8 meetings
everybody meets everybody agrees but
then actually to get through it and make
a change happen is I think what great
leadership requires okay so I'm on step
three which is conduct a root cause
analysis of the delegates in the room
comedy have done a root cause analysis
Siraj everybody okay great most okay so
our goal here was for you in your team
since you don't necessarily you don't
have that much work experience with each
other though the methodology might be
straightforward you're actually going to
the workout room to do a root cause
analysis of the problem you've decided
to work on is what our hope was that you
would do and so let's just talk a little
bit about what we mean by root causes
what we really mean is these are the
underlying reasons and the underlying
reasons for the problem itself what are
the root causes that you should focus on
that's another story because obviously
if you go out you could come up and I
don't know if you've had this experience
with thousands of different reasons that
things occur wrong thousands of
different reasons for maternal mortality
etc the question is how of all of that
do you make way so you know which root
causes to focus on and so just a couple
of criteria by which you might decide
which to focus on one root cause that
you would want to focus on is the test
if I fix this will the problem go away
that would be a great root cause to
focus on is it something that has large
impact is it one of the major causes is
it feasible to do anything about it or
do you just have to live with it and
last will it have lasting impact without
causing yet another problem and we often
talk about unintended effects of
interventions got to think about that
will the root cause you're talking about
if you deal with it will it have a
lasting impact without causing new
problems at this point when we think
about what kinds of tools might we be
able to use to do a root cause analysis
there are thousands of different tools
and you probably have gone through many
of them we were actually just focusing
on two different tools here the first
one that we wanted to focus on really is
sort of fishbone diagram identifying all
possible causes through what would be
basically be like a brainstorming
session and what's good about doing this
is everybody seat has anybody seen a
fishbone diagram before yeah you've seen
it's on your slides just look forward
one okay but tell me what you think is
good about doing something that
you brainstorm and everybody puts their
ideas on the table what's really good
about that you you might be thinking
causally so that's good
say it again cause and effect yeah
and we heard who was it who told us
earlier today you have to be curious I
like that because it's always thinking
what's my cause why did this happen what
how can I fix it okay so one thing is
you you're thinking about things that
are causing and having an effect what
else is good about doing this
brainstorming so it takes energy it
takes time you go sit down you gotta
listen to everybody talk what's good
about it yeah you just get all all the
options so you're less likely to tunnel
down into something that's wrong yeah
anything else so you can think of that's
good about cuz then of course I'm gonna
ask you what's bad about it yeah you
might get some buy-in I would tell me
what you mean by that buy-in okay so
that's one thing where you might just be
more likely to have acceptance by the
people who have to implement it if
actually they've helped donate the
reasons for it right but there are
probably other reasons to get all the
information and you're absolutely right
about that of it'll just be easier to
implement if they've been part of it and
I know here in the US we use that
rationale a lot for the reason that we
would include everybody what about if
you're in an environment where you know
no matter what the people who you're
working with aren't gonna feel empowered
you're in a society where that might not
happen is this still a good thing to do
Juliet's us know how good I like I like
controversy why not Julia
okay so we're go ahead okay so in this
situation you're saying you know you
brainstorm and all of a sudden you have
all this disagreement nobody can get
consensus and you've sort of made it
worse in a way because Pandora's box we
call it here is put everything out and
then what you do so certainly this issue
of brainstorming and fishbone diagram
there is this tension between is it
Angela yeah Angela
Angela's point of well but it'll engage
everybody and Juliet's point that but
then how do you move forward because
people aren't really agreeing on things
enough and I go ahead what did you say
somebody said solution it's what
negotiate then potentially you could
find a way to resolve if you have the
full information out absolutely one
thing I was going to say about this
issue of what's good about getting all
the information out even if you're in a
situation where participation is not the
culture is not going to happen
people feel disempowered which it's not
a pleasant situation but if you're in
that situation there's a good reason to
still get all the information out which
is if you're the decision-making you
will understand better even if
ultimately not everybody gets a voice at
the table because that's just how it is
even in that situation if you have
greater understanding because everybody
has a piece of the elephant that you're
trying to see that in itself just can
make for better decision-making you're
more informed and the issue of whether
it also gets buy-in is sort of an added
benefit I think Juliet's point however
was oh the second thing I'm going to
talk about I said let me go right to the
fishbone for a minute okay so here we
have facilitates brainstorming and
organize as many ideas ensures wide
engagement to Angela's point but to
Juliet's points it doesn't really help
with prioritizing and it can set you
back instead of forward
you can actually
and 20 minutes brainstorming and come
out feeling like I'm never gonna get
anywhere my own view is we should still
do it because it helps us understand
better but we do need some way after
that to go past all the great ideas and
actually start to prioritize and make
decisions for action yeah you wanta
because brimstone will bring out the
ideas and they are clear rules that you
don't challenge what other people say so
usually what makes the fishbowl any more
important is when you use a fishbone
diagram as maybe a second step in your
analysis the brainstorm brings the
issues out and then the next step you go
proper to is a prioritize when you
prioritize then the third step is using
the fishbone
I wish point now you take a problem and
then you'll be asking if someone gives
an a response you may be asking about
why this happened so that it makes
people to think forward and forth and
forth to the point where they may be
exhausted but again it allows a lot of
exchange of ideas and people can
actually be thinking and someone talk
about ownership that way that at that
point the owner of the ownership issue
comes into play people themselves a few
years unless I'm being listened to but
if we use the fishbone diagram and link
it and mix away with brainstorming then
it gets a little bit confusing you don't
get the result you want to get it's a
good comment let's go to a picture let's
go to a fishbone diagram just so we have
sort of concrete because this the first
issue you raise dr. bar people are very
important about is really fish moaning
sorry is having a fish
phone tryig Ram the same or different as
brainstorming and you see your
brainstorm be free get it all out and
organize it then on a fishbone
I actually am in full agreement with you
I've of course seen this done in not a
very prioritizing way but just anything
anyone says goes on the fishbone that
could be good or bad depending on your
kind of situation but let's take a look
at it the problem statement here I
couldn't write it all out but what we
mean here is a long wait time between
emergencies symptoms let's say onset and
actually getting emergency care being
treated just a long wait time now that
could be due to thousands of things
thousands of things so one could have
done a maybe it's a brainstorming or
maybe it's brainstorming plus
prioritizing to get the picture out here
and somebody might say in the group the
reason that we have such a long time
between when the person feels they need
a merger when the symptoms come and when
they get to actually get care
it may be because there are too few
emergency service facilities around here
or someone might say no we just there's
plenty of them but there's no
transportation can't get there on time
when we need to or someone else might
say actually there's plenty of them but
when you get to the emergency department
it's so crowded and so difficult it
takes forever and you wait another thing
someone could say at the top there it
costs too much that's why people don't
go it costs too much just a couple more
of these under equipment you could say
well they get there but then when they
get there there's no equipment or
medications so they actually don't get
treated they get nothing the last sort
of domain here people you could have a
lack of knowledgeable sort of lack of
knowledge relative to the reasons to
refer the rural health workers may not
fully have guidelines and understand the
reasons to refer to emergency facility
or maybe the staffing in the emergency
facility is not is not adequate when you
look at these different potentials what
comes to mind
relative to this you know if your team
had just done this what comes to mind
about your ability to move forward from
this spot yeah Angela yeah it's just
kind of overwhelmed huh sort of chaotic
too because isn't it kind of organized
in a way well some of this is about the
facilities and some of this is actually
about community people and what they
understand sums about the rural some of
its the delay from my house to the place
some of its from the entrance of the
place actually
just all over the board but this is not
uncommon and I think sometimes as
leaders we kind of try to close it down
too early and say oh it's too confusing
don't think about that actually creating
some ambiguity some flexibility some I'm
just not sure what which way I'm going
could potentially open us up to find
creative ways in which these things work
together but we have to manage the
intense complication and confusion chaos
that come from it which I hope our
Pareto diagram will help with in a
moment this issue about organizing it in
the four wings that's just there could
be any themes that you wanted it's a
method to try to organize like ideas
together different people do it
different ways you know I think it can
be driven by the kind of problem that
you're particularly working on now the
issues with this which dr. Barbara and
Angela Juliette all raised in different
ways were gee you know is there really
priority setting when you do this or
have you just sort of brainstorm put
stuff out and organize it maybe it gets
some by and but maybe it creates more
confusion and lack of consensus than we
really need so my view at this point is
the other piece of sort of root cause
analysis that's critical is evidence now
this is a good place where data can be
very helpful to have one actually decide
on the priority root causes that one
will eventually design strategy to
overcome
thousands and thousands of different
ways to do this different consultants to
hire to run regressions and do a lot of
different things the basic sort of
thought process I think has been very
well informed by great thinker Pareto
and Pareto diagrams have been named to
sort of quantify how often the problem
that in this case is the delay in
emergency care is due to each of the
possible root causes we would never want
to have to do studies of those forty
things that were out there but having
some data about some of those root
causes and how often each one is
associated or is present can help us
sort of identify where we are with
things and obviously there are many more
complex ways to look at this however I
think at root when we are actually
working on operational problems where we
are trying to explain why we're doing
what we're doing and really that's half
of leadership job is to be able to
communicate this to large audiences
don't want to get overly complex
for instance the main concept and
actually maybe I'll ask you what's the
main concept of a Pareto diagram like
this what's the sort of main take-home
point here
besides it simple yeah it's a visual
it's a visual how big a problem is and
what do you mean by that like here we
have perceived quality on the y-axis the
percent of the delays if you could
measure that that is attributable to the
the person the individual really not
thinking they're going to get very good
care perceived quality we would say that
if we ran a study of this eighty percent
of the time that was the dominant reason
for the delay if these were the data or
maybe about seventeen percent of the
time it was because there was no
transportation and maybe two or five
percent of the time it was perceived to
do because of cost
heaven forbid these are not real data
but it sort of gets you to I guess the
question John
did he leave where's John ah John you
took your coat off and then you were
asking it's sort of how do you bring
evidence and and my own view of this is
the kind of evidence we need to move
policy is actually often pretty simple
evidence Julio Frank was here to talk
about how he really used evidence to
drive mexico's adoption of its health
insurance and really said the main thing
I needed to know is what percentage of
the dollars were being spent by the
private sector out-of-pocket versus not
that's not a gigantic study that's like
a Pareto diagram saying well how often
is the care not being given due to which
kind of due to which kind of cause so
again I think there's many many more
sophisticated approaches to this kind of
work but at root the benefit of a Pareto
diagram is it tells you if 80 percent of
the problem is due to that root cause
that's the place to target strategy and
so the fishbone in the Pareto diagram
work in opposite directions one sort of
getting all the information out and the
Pareto may be helping to prioritize
these things so that's the that's the
approach do you buy that dr. Bower Bluff
yeah okay good and if you want to go
back to the fishbone after this that
would make some sense - let me just talk
briefly about developing possible
strategies the goal for today when you
go to work out in your own sessions will
be to conduct a root cause analysis
of the problem you've brought to work on
and to start to think through developing
possible strategies to get at least this
far through just talk a bit about what
we mean by developing strategy I guess
the first thing is each strategy is
gonna be a set of actions it's not going
to be one action obviously you have huge
responsibilities in your country so a
strategy really is a set of multiple
interventions that can happen no
question about that we don't want you to
think small in any way on this
nonetheless I think as we consider all
the possible things we could do possible
strategies we could do there's several
sort of again criteria by which we could
judge which one would make the most
sense to do so a good strategy and I'd
love to flesh this out further with your
experience but a good strategy
accomplishes the objective first thing
it actually is effective you think it
will accomplish something again data
could be used to say will this
accomplish it it's feasible
it recognizes interrelationships which
ties to a concept John Gatiss and Paul
Kennedy raised on Monday I don't know if
that concept was apparent to everyone
but that their interrelationships to
math managed what did they call that and
they had a cool word for it the ecology
of our health system they kept coming
back to that a great strategy has some
degree of flexibility you you're sure
you're going to go this way but you have
to improvise
there's no way not to improvise this
happened yesterday to us we've had great
scholars here talking about history and
grand strategy and about an hour through
Leslie and I said oh my goodness we
really have to tie this to health and so
you improvise quickly and that again is
a good way to go with strategy and our
last great strategy has broad
stakeholder or leadership support are
there things on here that you think have
benefited and make a better strategy a
were strategy that sort of aren't
already reflected here in your own
experience
yeah Angela say it again you have the
means to do it
it sort of beats say it again grand
strategy marry the means yes that the
means so that's sort of what's meant by
accomplish the objective it will the
means there's going to be a good
strategy the means that you're going to
use to actually accomplish the grand
objective if you will they they should
be absolutely tied yeah okay okay so
let's go back to the issue about the
wait time again just to pull this
example through possible strategies to
address wait time so I'm just going to
take three for the fun of it and they
could be totally different ones but
let's pretend that we had done a study
so that we knew these were these were
potential strategies that dealt with
prevalent root causes
one being implement referral guidelines
to encourage rural health workers to
refer patients to facilities as soon as
possible to being improved the roads and
purchase ambulances you know get deal
with the transportation and three being
enhanced the quality of care in
emergency facilities now I try to take
these three only because they're easy to
talk about they're small compared to the
kinds of things you're going to be
working on but we don't want to be here
all day we want to give you the time to
work so just for sake of discussion
they're a single action each of them but
how would you decide among these how
would you decide they're all maybe
they're all good how would you decide
yeah so you would look at criteria for
each one and you try to sort of balance
them based on those criteria what's
other ways in which people might think
between the different strategies what's
feasible what's feasible which might end
up being one of the criteria but like
its feasibility up what else yeah each
strategy pit them against each other
based on cost maybe cost effectiveness
the bang for the buck yeah yes the fast
though are the most results sorry the
most results in did you mean fastest and
greatest time I thought that's where you
were about to go absolutely so if we go
to this step 5 of comparing the
strategies on Common Criteria
we want to as Cara had said use criteria
to compare them and then organize your
data again is another place where
evidence and data and research could
really be used to select between
strategies because in an ideal world you
would have a litany of papers or
evidence or small-scale studies that had
been done to sort of say I know this
strategy looking at the evidence carries
this cost and has this impact that's the
ideal but of course as leaders you won't
be doing those studies you'll be taking
that evidence from all over the place
and hopefully synthesizing it for
decision making and I guess though this
seems perhaps simple how often we don't
do it and we were all talking about how
the research evidence is over here but
actually using it to pick the strategy
and make a decision it's not done that
much I think this is sort of central for
all of us in thinking about which
evidence we should be getting and then
how we can translate it into a decision
yeah yeah
we the influences here from partners and
stakeholders because in each country at
a country level each stakeholder has his
or her own ideas and concerns and
likeness of different strategies and
sometimes this also come into play in
helping you to make a decision a sample
in Liberia we were at a point of
determining which strategy to use for
health financing how do we find as a
health care delivery system and it was a
big big dialogue among our international
partners USAID on one side the World
Bank on one side David on one side with
the EU and we had to suggest and
everybody was bringing evidence but but
the good thing is that the evidence they
were bringing we're evidence when
Liberia so they were very evidence
Rwanda from Ghana the World Bank said
okay Ghana did a very good thing social
insurance and so we had a stop to say
okay we agree with you but we want to
generate our own evidence we want to
want to dip behind and see what what has
worked in this country and then we will
all come together and decide which way
yes you've made two incredibly important
points there and let me just put all
these up because it will get to it some
of the criteria I think already raised
in the room where its effectiveness its
cost I sort of raised it's time to
effect and dr. bar Paulo has raised the
issue of stakeholder support and that is
absolute critical now we said political
support but that was not meant to mean
literally political small fee
I don't know your partner your
stakeholders all of them international
national stakeholders I really like your
second point of so what evidence do we
believe this is a gigantic question and
I think you're absolutely right
while some of our earlier speakers put
an awful lot of trust in evidence the
fact is even though it's a statistic and
there's a p-value on it there's a lot of
wobble around what the evidence says how
you frame it how the method was done
what the measurement was what the
multivariate model looked like what the
inputs were enormous enormous we we have
this experience very much using the in
USAID model to estimate lives saved in
Ethiopia over their rural initiative and
again you're always look at that okay
that's an assumption okay it's an
assumption so you're absolutely right
that people could bring evidence which i
think is a call for us and you for sure
to get really good at understanding and
evaluating evidence and say this is
credible to me in Liberia or this is not
credible to me and librarian I think the
knee-jerk action of saying no no no I
won't believe it unless it's done in my
country is not always that helpful
because it it isolates us from what
actually can be learned there's some
medium there where some things are
useful and then some replication in the
country but I think you're absolutely
right to be a little cynical potentially
about evidence that's given to revalue
critical you know evaluating whether it
works or not and in fact if we take
these criteria and then try to compare
the strategies across criteria this is
nothing more than two boxes the top box
is qualitative if you will and the
bottom box is quite more quantitative
but no magic at all and on the left side
under strategies are the three we had
talked about just to be simple implement
referral guidelines build roads and amp
by ambulances enhance the perceived
quality of facilities now so far I've
sort of talked
about those as being separate and you do
one you don't do the a you're picking
which is best oftentimes people come to
this and say well those are all great
I'll do them all what I will do is they
all look good on and do em all so the
issue what do you think about that if
someone goes through this and no
actually maybe we should describe it
first and then you can tell me what you
would do so across the top are the
criteria effectiveness cost time and
political support or stakeholder support
you could pick whatever criteria work
for your problem they will be different
depending sometimes cost is not an issue
sometimes time is not an issue but
that's really up to your team's and this
is qualitatively just talking through
for instance the effectiveness of
implementing referral guidelines you
might say I'm not saying this is true
from evidence
I'm just saying pretend you had the
evidence you would might say that's low
build roads and ambulances you might say
that's medium enhanced perceived quality
of facilities you might say that's high
now in terms of its effectiveness now
getting to populate that box what do you
need you need evidence you need studies
you need or you need experience you need
your own experience or good consultants
that you believe in or coaches that can
provide this kind of information what
the leadership team is doing is
organizing it in a way that a decision
can be made not actually running the
study which is trying to organize these
types of things and again on the bottom
is nothing more than trying to put some
numbers on these things to sort of say
well if three is my best and one is my
worst or three is very good and one is
not so good effectiveness the first
implement referral guidelines its
effectiveness you know is low I'm going
to attribute that a1 and etc populating
that box adding up and getting a total
so what are just some thoughts you have
reactions to this because I think one of
the things though we're always trying to
build this leaders is sort of critical
thinking so there's some great things
about this and there are some horrible
things about this so I'm curious your
own thinking it through reaction
jon's laughing yeah yeah mm-hmm you mean
like waiting how heavily absolutely so
you could embellish it and you could
wait you could embellish it and you
could you know use Excel or whatever
you're gonna do and you could wait feeds
so let's pretend we do that now it's
still still things are wrong with this
so I think so let's say we wait it yeah
so it's still going to be a choice in
terms of how you select amongst that and
I've actually used a similar tool that
Columbia University had developed on
prior setting prior strategic framework
for setting priorities and we ran into
that when you rank several interventions
and then you have scores that are very
similar then you still have a lot of
back-and-forth with the stakeholders as
to how you select the ones that you're
going to work on x1 so actually this is
sort of a situation like that because 10
is awfully close to 9 okay maybe 6 is
worse so you it's not clear you could
come out with things that are actually
quite similar or I would go so far as to
add even if they are a little bit
dissimilar it's only an aide it sort of
is just a way to organize a debate
rather than tell you this is what you're
going to do because it's like a tool
like a hearing aid to help you sort of
hear it better but it can't actually
make the full decision for you in that
case particularly in the situation where
things come out very similarly I think
people are heavily bought into this
approach however would go back and say
well there must be some other criteria
that will we could put into this to
separate them because if they're truly
all the same value then it's sort of a
joint point us on that but yep so that's
another issue other issues that you
might see with this yeah sorry
hi we're working with the assumption
the greatest value is the best option
but oftentimes it might in fact be that
you're better off with with smaller
quicker wins to show results sooner and
with greater impact than one big great
impact good so and in fact I suppose you
could trick the matrix to serve you by
waiting time very heavily and having
something quick means more so you could
kind of trick the math to do what you
want to do but you would need to think
that through if that was really what you
wanted to reflect absolutely I think the
other thing that for me is problematic
but again I think it's a nice way to
organize things just as decision-makers
and communicators but from a research or
evidence-based problem who knows what's
inside this matrix why is something 3 or
2 or 1 how do you inform that how good
is that data is it a vote is that we've
read the literature and this is what we
think it is you know what do you do and
I think that you know experts get better
and better at delivering this evidence
so that it can be used for this kind of
decision-making but those I think are
just some of the challenges when we
cross the line from just doing a study
that we can go publish to actually
trying to create data that can be used
in some way to make a decision for a
policy maker
my takeaway from this approach is it
helps a conversation to think in terms
of criteria to think in terms of wait
what are my alternatives and on what
criteria am i evaluating them it brings
a certain rationale to the debate of
what otherwise can kind of fall down
into just arguing back and forth back
and forth it brings a little more logic
and evidence and rationale to it but it
certainly doesn't replace what do you
think we ought to do it's sort of super
ration which helps but of course there's
the irrational and the sort of
negotiation that occurs as well so I
think it's helpful but it's not at all a
panacea yeah
might not be here at this point to
consider this but a lot of these
problems there may be many approaches
and strategies occurring in the
countries and so I'm wondering if it's
like here you might want to consider
you're not the only one who's coming up
with that strategy so is there a measure
of I don't know the group like you said
it's hard to know what that measure is
but it's sort of a way to track whether
you think that's an area that's
beneficial to join in doing or done
sufficiently maybe there's another part
of the problem you must have an example
in your mind is there an example and so
there are a lot of strategies that
others are tackling in that area yeah
yep and so I'm just wondering should you
know in doing this actually starting to
compare strategies I guess how do you
bring in that understanding of others
are doing parts of some of those
strategies or join with them I think
good so what you're saying is there are
tons of different decision-makers and
actors and agents and if you choose one
someone else might be choosing to at
which point one is just fine because two
is covered I mean I think that's what
you're saying is it's your decisions
synergy with what else might be going on
in the country and I think that could be
brought into one of the criteria like
this augments what else is happening or
is antagonistic to what else is
happening I think that would probably be
the the the strongest place but I mean
you are raising a very very good point
about sort of a super rational approach
to this - in a single group decision
maker as opposed to multiple parties
where you're almost in a game a game
theory with each other if they move this
way I would move that way that's it I
think you can sort of
assumptions as you go into this of what
the other parties are already covering
and reflect that in some of the criteria
but so very it's a good point okay I'm
gonna move on from where we are with a
problem solving we were on here select
the strategy yeah oh go ahead please
yeah effectiveness cost time and
political support
I don't exert they have equal grid
probably maybe I would prefer to give
effectively the highest grade to cost
then you have to multiply the weight
that you have given to each by the grid
that you give to each strategy for
example if effectiveness it gets five
from five cost 4 from 5 times 3 4 from 5
political support 2 from 5 then I will
multiply one by five then I'll give that
the box for implement referral
guidelines and factory so I think it
will give us an unbiased grade and it
will be really feasible I mean it will
facilitate the decision-making process
so I think we should not give equal
value for effectiveness cost time and so
on
there's a very important point that our
left raised is that sometimes there is a
situation or a scenario that you have to
implement two or three strategies than
just one strategy yes yes very good so
both of those let's just review them
quickly waiting these differently is
very important and that's a value
judgment and understanding that each
team should work with that makes sense
for them the issue of sometimes you just
got to do two of these like you might
analyze this and say they're all good I
need to do all three of them if you were
really going to do a comparative
analysis each of these lines would
probably have multiple actions in them
like one strategy might be we're gonna
build out roads and ambulances and
improve the quality of facilities that
could be a strategy then there'd be
another one that wasn't that because
it's an alternative something you in
other words you want to set them up so
they're all
to each other so you can pick the one
even if it's a composite one that
actually is better than the others if if
you go through the whole thing and at
the end of it say oh we're gonna do them
all then in some way you haven't really
done a comparative analysis you've just
sort of valued each one and said they're
okay you haven't thought opportunity
cost if I do this I can't do that but
you could write each strategy as a set
of interventions which would make some
sense okay is it okay to go on okay so
problem solving steps so number six you
would select the strategy and as cokie
described you might just take the
highest score or if the it doesn't make
any sense you might be using that only
as a guide and then select a strategy
based on some other criteria as well one
issue we didn't actually discuss very
much that i think can be very helpful is
you can at this point in making the
decision you can think about some type
of sensitivity analysis for instance i
meant to say this here if you really
have no certainty over what how long
something will take for instance you
could say to yourself well if this ended
up taking a long time so I only got a 1
on that instead of a 2 to enhance the
quality of facilities I say you know I'm
not sure I think this is going to take
much longer than that you could redo
this changing that piece of information
and see how it affects the outcome in
other words since there's so much
uncertainty around a lot of these things
you could do a sensitivity analysis to
know if you change some of these numbers
or some of these assumptions will it
change what strategy you're going to
select and that can make something a
little bit more robust potentially and
easier to communicate so that even as
people say oh we can't do that because
it cost too much you might say well no I
actually redid it even with those high
costs
and it's still the thing that we want to
do okay so that's the end of that the
select the strategy the only point I
have there is evaluating these with
qualitative and quantitative data listen
to reason and intuition we heard a lot
about this the issue of balancing sort
of paradoxes and leadership that it's
never all reason for all intuition but
some kind of balance between these be
clear on choice this was just the point
that we just were talking about dr. your
belt el is saying well we'll just do
everything is probably not having really
done a comparative analysis but really
making choices is really ultimately what
the leadership piece will be so for the
moment for no better reason than it's
just how the numbers worked out an
example here would be our choice would
be enhanced the perceived quality of
facilities that's what we would come up
with from that kind of analysis again
that's not at all based on data is just
an example so the last two steps of this
are the creating an implementation plan
and create evaluation plan again we
don't necessarily have to be doing these
in perfect order but this is where we
wanted to go as well and and we're
actually quite hopeful that you'll start
to think through these pieces as well as
you're addressing your problem and why
do you think this implementation plan
part is very important or not very
important what what's your reaction to
actually having an implementation plan
on something like these huge problems
you've brought this is a valuable thing
to do to are not so valuable it should
be someone else's job what do you think
yeah Suraj
whenever we identify strategy we have to
have the implementation plan for the
strategy otherwise we will end up in
getting nothin without nothin yeah we do
have we must have time went to
accomplish that and we must identify who
is going to do what and what resources
that we are using this whole thing is
should be identified in the first thing
so that we can evaluate that they know
whether we have achieved so that's very
Pro implementation plan and I think you
described this of an implementation plan
sort of having a list of the actions and
the sequencing of those actions could be
in lots of different names for it I've
chosen the name of Gantt chart assigning
the person you described that who would
be accountable for the tasks and sort of
the overall governance of the plan a
piece of the implementation plan will
we'll talk about a minute is also this
managing the resistance which I think is
a lot of what John Gaddis was talking
about when he referred to friction but
before we get there just going to this
action plan I know many of you have seen
something like this and I want you to
think Siraj just gave oh yeah you've got
to have one of these you need to do
something like this I also want to talk
about what happens as we do this because
I'm curious how many people have
actually got something like this on some
strategy you are trying to do and
actually it wasn't followed how many
people have that experience you're
longing everybody has that experience
the whole world has that experience
so let's first see what it is and that's
understand why we never follow them so
the implementation plan that we're
talking about is on the left are the
action strategies the big I'm sorry the
action items the big strategy is enhance
perceived quality of emergency
facilities that's what we said we were
going to do from the comparative
analysis now implementing this what are
the actions that have to be taken I have
no idea whether these are the right or
the wrong actions they're just an
example but for instance there
a much lower level like establish a set
of clinical standards for care and
quality of care measures develop
management capacity and Human Resources
in those facilities improve the supply
chain for essential medicine and
equipment established pay for
performance methods again controversial
but just pretend I select that and five
develop public reporting system of
quality measures the second column is so
who will do it who's responsible for it
and these columns at the quarter one two
three four out to ten when how they
should be sequenced who should be doing
what so how many people have this in
their office some on some strategy you
all probably have an action plan that
you're on right and what's your
experience using these action plans
Suraj it's working though right maybe oh
boy but Angela Erin well first of all we
didn't begin when we said we wouldn't
begin so everything else got pushed back
and then we forgot entirely about the
plan and went about doing what we needed
to do as the as the intervention
demanded haha uh-huh okay so not
starting when we said we would start and
then not keeping to it what are other
people's experience same thing did
someone just say same thing same Julia
yeah Julie did you want to I said
funding funding if the funding is coming
from a donor sometimes they don't
coincide with your action plan even
though has been said you know you've set
guidelines and everything they might
have red tapes or if you're waiting for
ta ta might not be available
set because somebody hasn't put the TA
or had the TA proper there or they
haven't put the budget or you haven't
really you've hit a block okay and often
when we hit a block and we hit millions
of them we take an action plan like this
and just it goes on the shelf then we're
done because it already was off kilter
from the first day it was off kilter and
then someone else caused you a problem
on step three now it's really off kilter
the best thing to do is not to do that
the best thing to do is think about the
action plan is a living document you
know it's sort of like your own personal
budget at home or your own to-do list
that you bring with you it is got to be
a living document that changes all the
time because if it isn't a living
document it just goes to the shelf and
then it's never used and then there
really isn't a plan you can't
communicate it that well you don't
really have the evidence about the
particular thing and it falls into a
lack of productivity and particularly in
your roles demonstrating with
informality that this is actually the
approach and it will be changed if
deadlines have to be pushed out they get
pushed out but clearly bringing this
into I think one of the reasons we often
put it away as we haven't met it but
maybe what we should do is say well
let's reformat it then we made a
rational decision we delayed that let's
do it again you know in a more I think
the other thing that often happens is
these get really complex they might have
800 lines on them project management
gigantically complex and clearly it's
important for somebody to be keeping
track of those details but the idea of
what actually you have as your big
picture is critical in that for the
first time in the health sector in
Liberia because we're able to get a
national health plan and then we
collectively met to develop an annual
operational plan that everyone in the
health
knows about and put in a very rigid
monitoring process in place where every
three months the entire health sector
meets to review the performance of the
last three months and set new targets
for the following three months and also
meeting every year that is added agreed
date together this has helped to change
things it is more of a living situation
that changes regularly I mean I guess
that's the point if these things don't
change they aren't going to be useful
yeah let's go to the piece of
implementation that's outside this which
is really managing the resistance to
change and just a couple of thoughts on
this and I'd like your thoughts as well
I guess
the literature is we look back to it
would say that resistance to change is
absolutely expected in any
problem-solving action and in fact the
growing resistance often is a sign that
the change is really starting to take
place people actually ignore you if they
don't think you're gonna do anything
they're not resistant at all they're
quiet they think creat you're gonna do
pay-for-performance
see you later and they're not they're no
resistant but then you start to get the
feed structures and you actually start
to do it in all of a sudden Wow all this
resistance and you wonder well I had a
meeting with you about it I told you
this is what we're gonna do why now are
you resistant but that resistance is
actually a sign they're taking you
seriously that this is gonna happen it's
a good sign if somebody isn't arguing
that this doesn't make sense
you maybe are not getting through to
them they maybe haven't heard because
they're in the status quo if you're
bringing in change and they aren't
saying wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute
then maybe change isn't happening and
they're quietly going about to do it
just the way they always did it while
you write your pay for performance
policies so this
this idea that resistance is the time to
stop is I think very wrong now it's
certainly a time to say wait a minute
what am i doing am i right do I have my
evidence is this really what I believe
there's no question about that but it
isn't necessarily a sign that you've
made a mistake or your team has chosen
the wrong strategy or you've used the
wrong implementation in fact it might be
a sign that really you're making some
progress so from the sort of grand
strategy principles we would want to
anticipate the resistance we'd want to
know who's not going to like this who's
gonna lose in this and really develop a
plan as part of the implementation plan
for managing that resistance before and
as it occurs so that it doesn't seem
like it comes out of nowhere but you
very much expected it and you had kind
of a plan for what you were going to do
with that and in fact we have sort of
back to this example not specific to
emergency room waiting time but
different ways just from the literature
of managing resistance I think rather
than my articulating it I'd love to hear
from you all of you have had some of
this experience managing resistance is
there one or two key lessons learned
you'd say that's been very very
successful in managing resistance and
then I'll add my list you know what I
mean by people disagreeing with you
right about which way you're gonna go
what do you do someone disagrees what do
you do yeah you both
communicate communicate communicate
communicate okay are you a benefit very
good communication strategy definitely
there will not be any reasons as people
will continue okay let's say you
communicate really well and you do
everything right and you've made a
really good argument that this is going
to benefit you and by a rational point
of view you just really have informed
people why still might you have the
resistance and what do you do about it
even if you communicate yeah I you have
anything yeah yeah seeing that we have
to get people who understand you and
then you evolve the other people and
there are some people who are certainly
will understand you so you move along
with them on them kind of a group that
understands you is that what you're
saying you get you guys are to develop
champions I mean we fought this there
must be people who all of them should I
agree but not everybody will agree so I
believe in order to push it forward and
it may be that the person raising an
issue it's important to understand what
their concerns are perhaps there's a way
to do what you want the way you want and
still address their problem and secondly
there may be good ideas coming at this
point that you haven't heard about so
it's important to be flexible and
actually take those into account and
maybe turn a resistor into a supporter
yeah and it really highlights this great
paradox of having to be both at once
confident optimistic I know where I'm
going I'm expecting the resistance and
completely flexible listening to what am
i hearing and do I need to adopt adapt
in one way or another leadership is hard
yeah sometimes resistance come because
people feel like they didn't been
involved since the very beginning so
they just resist to show that you should
have been involved them since the very
beginning
so sometimes it's good to just assign
the most resistant to some of the the
tasks to implement or plateau to to to
see how you can involve them more and it
is over but it depends with the
situation and of course you're raising a
great point about leadership about
engaging people who truly are different
that don't maybe believe what you
believe but engaging them into the
process so that what you understand
about the phenomenon is accurate that
you have all the voices represented a
phenomenal leadership thing to do but it
just pains our guts sometime to do it
right you're doing it oh this is so
difficult but that of course I think is
as part of this yeah the the thoughts
these might trigger some other thoughts
that I didn't actually hear it's a lot
in the literature about developing a
sense of urgency to make the changes and
again I think this is really a critical
leadership paradox in the case that
somebody in the leadership role really
needs to read the outside environment
see what the urgent may be hostile
outside environment meaning the
difficulties the fears you know it
somehow as a leader you need to call
attention to people and sometimes that's
through fear like what's happening
outside this is what's happening it kind
of gets people alert but
immediately you have to be able to shift
to create what will be a safe learning
environment on the inside and as the
leader you're sort of the one mediating
that external scary environment that
creates a sense of urgency but then
immediately okay now we're gonna try to
learn together in a safe place and doing
both of those at once is quite complex
this developing a sense of urgency I bet
somebody in this class or this group has
used there are many things we heard
about this morning Michelle sort of
talked about how the sense of urgency
clicked in and then all these things
could happen so how can you use it it
should be part of the implementation
plan obviously maybe it's not written
out in your own minds developing a
guiding coalition who said that you said
that Ebenezer get a group a group that
sees it your way that can help guide you
and maybe give you criticism if you need
criticism and be the feelers out this
communicate dr. Yoo Bell tell the
short-term wins particularly the early
successes lots of literature on that
this to Mark's point I think anticipate
who may lose or who may resist and
negotiate and I would you're absolutely
right mark putting that in listen to
them understand them so that you can
negotiate and think what it is you can
offer despite the kinds of changes what
what do they need to feel better about
this change and can you somehow make
that need there yeah Dana a lot of times
in change management what we do is we
actually use the people who may lose and
negotiate and put them in the champion
group as long as they aren't too much of
naysayers because it really helps
provide that like okay I'm in the group
who's rejecting this change and I'm
gonna provide you feedback for what you
can do to make the change happen
absolutely absolutely yeah
Cokie just build on that I think as part
of the whole process of stakeholder
analysis at the outset also would help
so that you get to know who are your
champions and who are your naysayers and
you know you you build the strategy of
working with them
the way yeah and the other thing I was
going to joke about her just get them
fired of course with the easiest thing
but I think that you sometimes just have
to wait you know to you know in terms of
time to yes
you know get some change happen when
they have people move out of positions
be on a TV deal with I think you're
right I actually put that on the last
just keep at it I'm at the end you have
to have persistence and I guess haven't
heard Arielle I would say you have to
have hope and persistence have to always
think it is doable but none of the stuff
happens quickly or it would have
happened I mean I guess that's the
bottom line you're doing things that are
hard to do and if they were easy you
would not be called in to do it so just
keep at it I think is a large piece of
it yeah sorry I spaghetti when you the
plan was very good and after when you
start this spring we had more resistance
at the new new idea we try to found out
the causes of the resistance and then
when you found the we found this causes
for the distance we try to integrate in
the review of the plan and then we have
increased the performance and to reduce
resistance so what was the resistance
from and what did you do to overcome
that more possible resistance the main
resistance who comes from people who
deal with the business business with the
speaking the business of spraying yeah
or spear and now after we try to target
specific sectors with the high level of
my area and at the central level it was
their business they continued their
business and do it today or so to
communicate to show the performance and
write the data again the data to
demonstrate you're saving lives by doing
absolutely great example let's move on
because I bet you're getting tired and
it's getting a little late we started a
little late but I think we're about
where we should be
let's move on to the last piece of this
create an evaluation plan again all
caveats we should be thinking about
evaluation the minute we step into the
room but you know I thought maybe ending
with it would be helpful there's there's
really no right one way to evaluate the
impact of your strategy nonetheless
there are many many many good ways to do
it and so I do not want to pretend that
this is the only way by any means
whatsoever but I was trying just trying
to think about what really is practical
and we sit in this where you have large
jobs you have a lot of other things to
do too evaluation is critical to
understand a tractable way I mean a way
in which you can do it relatively simply
and you can communicate it relatively
simply as we tried to focus on so here
we've really just identified process
indicators and outcome indicators and
this data feedback loop issue is exactly
if you had said a manual you try to do
something and then actually getting the
data that helps evaluate it will just
make it move even faster make it move
even faster so a couple of principles
and specifying indicators one I think
it's absolutely critical is be precise
and I guess I have a little bit of an
academic hang-up about this but you
really want to be precise what is the
denominator what is the numerator for
any rate ratio or percent because how
often we are quoting things even in this
room oh we cut maternal mortality well
we did this we did our malaria rates
went down by what we
we are we saying and I think providers
of care particularly as we get into pay
for performance we get into quality
measures they really really they're
scientists right these are physicians
who are caring for patients they like
the academic literature they really want
to understand what are the data on which
they're being paid the numerator and the
denominator and there's so many this
complex particularly without
longitudinal records that it gets very
complex what the denominators properly
might be so be precise one thing second
understand the method of measurement but
be sure as sure as we can be that it's
reliable or comparable over time I like
the idea that we heard the global fund
director today say they're investing in
the data systems included to be able to
measure some of this clearly this is a
very very tricky spot it's how to do
measurement in a sustainable way where
ministries can be doing it on an ongoing
way with a method that it really is
reliable and can be compared over time
reducing some error or at least
recognizing the kind of bias we might
have and of course those two things are
very complex
so my last principle is keep it simple
this is I think sort of a critical thing
again for communication to move the data
into a policy realm we do have to limit
the number of indicators we talk about
two key ones and they've got to be
measured well it doesn't matter it may
be important at all kinds of levels have
many more indicators but ultimately the
ones that you're reporting are going to
be ones that really have to move a
population or have to move huge donor
groups in this example process and
there's a lot of again gray around what
is process and what is outcome so we
could have that debate I don't know if
it really gets us too far or not
ultimately what is literally the
indicator you're going to use in this
example of waiting time for emergency
terr we had a whole lot in the
implementation plan of process measures
that you could grab out of the
implementation plan perhaps someone
refer to these as monitoring indicators
etc but you could say yes no the
standards are developed and disseminated
wouldn't be very pleasing because you're
really trying to get to this outcome
wouldn't be very pleasing but it could
sort of be along the way you could say
yes no or by some percentage you've
improved staffing in the facilities you
could have a measure about we reduce
stock-outs
because we talked about the supply chain
as being one of the paths on the way you
could say we actually this is a larger
one we improved facility performance in
its quality measures because that's what
we're trying to do could go even further
and say we improved the public
perception of emergency facilities could
go there none all of those are processes
or interim outcomes because what was the
final problem that we were trying to
solve if you remember we were worried
about the wait time so I measured that
these are why this is process these
therefore don't really necessarily
measure the actual outcome the outcome
relatives are the process we are looking
at would be wait time so you could take
you know what percentage and you have to
think about the numerator and the
denominator but the wait time symptom
onset to actually accessing emergency
care and of course these outcome
indicators which could be thought of
right at the moment when you're setting
your objectives have to be fully in line
with what your objectives are so we're
hoping what can you accomplish in terms
of evaluation plan while you're here you
know our goal is you would at least
think through some process measures and
some outcome measures and put them
forward as indicators that's our goal is
that you would think about that
recognizing that of course this could
become far more complex as you start to
implement make sense to people what I'm
talking about without evaluation okay
let me give a couple of conclusions and
then happy to talk more about the
and talk more about your actual
assignment the conclusions are from our
perspective effective problem-solving
requires a very clear problem definition
from the beginning you hopefully have
come close to already doing that and to
focus on the objective so instead of
getting up in the morning and saying I
really want to do X we need to do X
instead we want to get up in the morning
and say I'm really trying to accomplish
Y what is the end that we're trying to
get to and I think that that does shift
it does shift a bit how we decide what's
on our to-do list is it driven by the
outcome I guess the second major
conclusion is that data are critical at
multiple points I mean we must have seen
it in 10 points here where we really
need data and we need data in a way that
is practical that can be used and then
used in analysis and then ultimately
drive a decision and the last conclusion
I would make is never go it alone and
emanuelly about how people have talked
about this is leadership in this kind of
problem solving which is going to be
very influential and involving many many
many different people requires strong
relationships partnerships would be the
word we heard so much this morning with
a guiding coalition that just weathers
out the rough spots when there obviously
will be many so I hope from this there's
sort of a few things I'm hoping you take
away from it one that you can maybe
implement and use this sort of problem
solving approach again remember we're
not terribly rigid if you think other
things would help you instead to address
your problem innovate go for it that's
fine
but also a really strong embracing of
what is data and evidence and how are
the partnerships that you're making that
are actually going to allow you to make
the changes you want to make